نتابع هذا التطور وهذا الموضوع مع السفير
سنن المجالي الناطق باسم الخارجيه
الاردنيه معالي السفير اهلا بك معنا اربع
طائرات الاردن وضعها في خدمه جاليته فداخل
السوداني حدثنا عن المزيد من التفاصيل لو
سمحت
[موسيقى]
الى مطار بور سودان وهي الان على على وشك
الاقلاع باتجاه الاردن ان شاء الله
عمليه الاجلاء او خطه الاجلاء كانت على
عده مراحل سيدتي اللي قام فيها الاردن
وتكاد تكون من العمليات الكبيره اللي حدثت
في السودان بلغ عدد الاشخاص اللي اللي تم
اجلائهم او سيتم اجلائهم تقريبا يفوق ال
300 شخص
من ضمنهم مواطنين من من دول صديقه
وشقيقه
عملنا جهد في في ضمان امن وسلامه
المواطنين الاردنيين من خلال الخطه التي
وضعت باحكام والتي قد تكون اخذت وقت طويل
ولكن الحمد لله النتائج كانت ايجابيه
ووصلوا للجميع بامن والسلام وان شاء الله
بيرجع الاردن
بسلام
استاذ مجال نتحدث عن اربع طائرات اي خطط
الاجلاء ستتم على مرحله واحده ام هذه خطه
تعتمد مراحل عديده او مرحلتين مثلا كما
فعلت بعض الدول الاخرى فرنسا
نعم سيدتي احنا العدد اللي تقريبا
دعونا المواطنين الاردنيين لمغادره
السودان
وتجاوبت الرجال الاردنيه الموجوده في
السودان باعداد
باغلبها تقريبا معنا في في هذه الخطه واود
ان اوجه لهم التحيه
للانضباط والصبر اللي اللي اللي مارسوه
معنا من خلال هذه الخطه التي كانت تخللتها
بعض الصعوبات تعلمين سيدتي الوضع ليس
بالسهل منطقه
بورسودان تبتعد عن عن عن الخرطوم باكثر من
1200 كيلو متر كان هناك صعوبات في في
للوصول الى الى منطقه برج
استاذ مجالي لو نتحدث اكثر عن هذه
التفاصيل من امن نقلهم من الخرطوم الى
مطار بورت سودان
نعم سيدتي نحن كوزاره خارجيه اردنيه قمنا
بتامين انتقالهم من
بورسودا من الخرطوم الى بورسودان بالكامل
ولكن تم هناك تنسيق مع العديد من الدول
وفي مقدمه ذلك
الاخوه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده وبعض الدول
الصديقه ممن كان العمل من خلال التنسيق
للبحث افضل السبل
والتعاون في تبادر المعلومات حول الممرات
الامنه ومراكز
ونقاط الاتصال هذا الامر كان غايه في
الاهميه سيدتي ساعد في انجاح هذه الخطه
العمليه بالظروف الامنيه افهم بانكم
تعاونتم مع الجانبين مع قوه مع الجيش
السوداني وكذلك مع دعم السريع
سيدتي نحن يعني بالاخر فيما يتعلق في
روابط الاخوه التي تربطنا مع الاشقاء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي الامارات
العربيه المتحده ومعظم الدول العربيه
نتعاون بشكل بشكل مطلق في كافه المجالات
بما في ذلك يعني موضوع
التعاون في في تبادل المعلومات والنقاط
الاتصال
من خلال
الجهود التي تقدمتها يعني وهذا التنسيق
الذي تم في هذا الموضوع
ونشكر
اسمح لي فقط ان افهم من حضرتك بمعنى انه
السلطات الاردنيه لم تتواصل مباشره مع
الدعم السريع او مع الجيش وانما تواصلتم
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع الامارات
المتحده وهم من مكنوكم من بعض الاخبار
وتفاصيل الممرات الامنه لوصول رعاياكم
الى مطار بورتسودان صحيح وضح لي صوره لو
سمحت
سيدتي نحن
[موسيقى]
اردني بامان الى المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه ووصولهم مقدم بالبدايه الى الى
ونشكر كل من ساعدنا في هذا في هذا الموضوع
طيب نتحدث عن جاليه اردنيه كبيره فداخل
السوداني تحدثني عن 300 شخص نفهم بان
ستكون هناك
مراحل اخرى مراحل ثانيه سيد مجالي
سيدتي العدد الجالي الاردنيه
بالسودان ليس بذلك العدد الكبير ونحن
عندما تحدثنا عن عن 300 شخص نقول انه
هؤلاء يمثلون
اغلب المواطنين الاردنيين الموجودين في
السودان هناك عدد متبقي في السودان حسب ما
نعلم ولكنه ليس اكبر من العدد الذي تم
اجلاؤه
بالمطبق اود شكرك على المشاركه وعلى ساعات
صدرك وسلامه لكل السلامه لكل الاردنيين
الذين خرجوا من السودان باتجاه المملكه
الاردنيه او تشكرك من عمان سفيرسنا
المجالي الناطق باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه
شكرا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات